we begin with some breaking news that's
come to us in the last few moments it
has been announced that liz truss will
take on uh the role of chief brexit
negotiator after lord frost's
resignation
last night she will do this uh as well
as her role as foreign secretary we're
gonna go straight over to westminster
into our political correspondent rob
powell and rob uh there'd been a lot of
conversation about who was going to get
this job and what that would mean so how
will this be received i think what we
can read into this is that boris johnson
has put someone into this brief
um who i think will be quite a popular
choice among backbench conservative
brexit supporting mps now
i say that um
partly despite the fact that liz trust
was someone that voted remain in 2016
but she is someone who fairly recently
um has been in the ascendancy within the
conservative party uh someone who is
seen as quite popular um and someone who
was seen as a potential successor to
boris johnson at some point um as well
now she will remain as foreign secretary
still relatively recently that she was
put into
that job but she will take on this role
as lead brexit negotiator
in addition to that a statement from
number 10 that was released um in the
last five to 10 minutes said that she'll
take over ministerial responsibility for
the uk's relationship with the eu with
immediate effect and she'll also become
the uk's co-chair of the partnership
council and the joint committee so we'll
lead on the ongoing negotiations around
the operation um of the northern ireland
protocol so those were the talks that
lord frost was heavily involved in that
have been
uh due to result resume um in um the new
year so um i i think this does show that
boris johnson was probably um aware of
the need to put someone in that
backbench conservatives uh would view as
quite a safe pair of hands someone that
wouldn't be um
a softer touch than lord frost to
reassure some of those conservative mps
that
had already been
criticizing boris johnson for other
issues or uncovered regulations and
various scandals going on in number 10
and of course that by-election loss
in north shropshire earlier in the week
so i think this is a move to try and
reassure them by putting someone in that
he knows will probably go down quite
well with that wing of the tory party um
number 10 also announcing some other
moves as uh as part of this as well
chris heaton harris and wendy morton two
ministers um uh in the um fco and the
department of transport are essentially
swapping briefs chris heath and harris
will come in as europe minister and
essentially deputised for liz trust in
the commons on brexit negotiations while
wendy morton swaps out and goes into the
department of transport but fair a
fairly quick uh and speedy um
replacement um and liz trust will really
have i think her work cut out for her um
given that um the she has a pretty
chunky brief as it is um and this has
now been um supplemented um with the
additional thorny task of trying to
hammer out some of those issues over the
northern ireland protocol
and oversee the uk's ongoing
relationship with the eu